uh welcome to the
simon's institute theoretically speaking
panel discussion on deep nets and the
primate visual system
my name is prasad raghavendra i'm a
senior scientist at the simons
institute of theory of computing the
simon's institute of theory of computing
is the world's leading venue for
collaborative research on theoretical
computer science it was established in
2012 with a grant from the science
foundation the institute brings together
uh world's leading research researchers
in critical computer science
today's lecture is part of our
theoretically speaking series which
highlights
exciting advances in theoretical
computer science for a public audience
when we are not limited by covet
restrictions these talks were held at
downtown berkeley with an audience from
a broader bay area community
before we get started i'd like to go
over how to ask questions in today's
event
we have people joining us here in calvin
lab
who will raise their hands and ask
questions
and those on zoom can type their
questions in the q a panel at the bottom
of the control panel the panel will
address as many questions as they can
during the qa session
today our distinguished panel moderator
is anila anilantha swami
anil is an award-winning journalist
former staff writer and deputy news
editor for the london-based new
scientist magazine
and
2019-2020 mit knight science journalism
fellow
he has been a guest editor for the
science writing program at university of
california santa cruz he's a freelance
editor at for the proceedings of the
national academy of sciences front
matter
he regularly contributes to quantum
magazine scientific american and other
repeated publications he has three books
to his name uh the edge of physics the
man who wasn't there and his latest
popular science book on quantum
mechanics through two doors at once
which was named one of the forbes 2018
best books on astronomy physics and
mathematics
please join me in welcoming anilanatha
swami
thank you very much prasad for that
introduction
and welcome everyone welcome to those
of you in calvin hall and also our
online audience and a big welcome also
to our panelists i'm going to introduce
our panel of experts
in um
alphabetical order of their last names
so
let me just go through
so we have with us uh
dr jim dicarlo who's a computational
neuroscientist
dr dicarlo is an investigator at the
mcgovern institute at mit he's the peter
d flores professor of neuroscience in
the department of brain and cognitive
sciences he was the former chair of the
depart of bcs and now is the director
at mit quest for intelligence which
seeks to understand human intelligence
within engineering terms and seeks to
apply that knowledge to build
machines that benefit society dr de
carlo's research goal
and his labs research goal is to reverse
engineer the brain mechanisms that
underlie human visual intelligence
we also have with us dr grace lindsay
who is also a computational
neuroscientist dr lindsay is a research
fellow at the sainsbury welcome center
gatsby computational neuroscience unit
university college london
her research interests are building
functional and interpretable models of
sensory processing
besides doing
research in in this area dr lindsay is
also actively
engaged in communicating these complex
ideas to a general audience her new book
is called models of the mind how physics
engineering and mathematics have shaped
our understanding of the brain we have
with us dr jitendra malik he is a
computer scientist here at uc berkeley
dr malik is the arthur j check professor
in the department of electrical and
engineering and computer sciences
and former uh chair of that department
he's a fellow of the ieee and the acm
member of the national academy of
engineering and the national academy of
sciences and a fellow of the american
academy of arts and sciences
uh dr malik has won numerous awards
among them being the 2016 acm aaa alan
newell award and the 2018 ijca award for
the research for research excellence in
ai his research interests include
computer vision computational modeling
of human vision and machine learning and
we also have with us dr santosh vimpala
who is a computer scientist dr vampala
is the frederick g story chair in
computing and professor of computer
science at georgia tech the founding
director of the algorithms and
randomness center and think tank at
georgia tech he was a miller fellow at
uc berkeley and also a sloan guggenheim
an acm fellow his research interests
include algorithms randomness geometry
and computing for good and more recently
he's become interested in computational
models of the brain
so
welcome uh everyone to this
panel discussion it's a it's a pleasure
for me to be moderating this session uh
give me a couple of more minutes before
we dive into the actual discussion i
would like to just present a couple of
slides there might be people in the
audience who are a little bit uh
unfamiliar with some of the terms and so
just so that we are all on the same page
i'm going to give a very very high level
take a very high level look at the
um sort of the basics of today's
discussion so we're essentially going to
be looking at how uh
deep neural networks are being used to
model the primate visual system and the
primary visual system that we are
talking about
is depicted here in this illustration uh
neuroscientists have known uh for
decades now that uh the primary visual
system particularly the human visual
system is uh it consists of two uh
primary pathways uh
uh distinct mostly distinct pathways so
if you look at the illustration the
information coming in uh into the eyes
and the information proceeds to
the back of the the brain where to the
visual uh cortices and there the
information uh stream splits into two in
the green you see the ventral stream and
in the red you see the dorsal stream
the ventral visual pathway is involved
in recognizing and representing patterns
faces and objects it's concerned with
what's uh in front of us
uh and in terms of the brain areas
involved in in the ventral visual stream
these are very areas called v1 v2 uh v4
uh and then downstream to uh areas in
the inferior temporal cortex the dorsal
visual pathway represents spatial
relations between objects it's concerned
with where objects are in relation to
each other and helps us helps guide our
actions
and today we're mostly going to be
concerned about the ventral visual
pathway because that's where most of the
modeling has been focused uh but i would
imagine that our panelists will address
how that modeling can be extended to the
other parts of the visual system the
other aspect of today's discussion will
involve deep neural networks anyone
who's been paying any attention to
machine learning and ai over the last
decade is well versed with these terms
but again just to bring everyone up to
to bring everyone onto the same page
we're going to be talking about deep
neural networks which are artificial
neural networks composed of layers of
artificial neurons these eminem-like
things that you see on the screen are
individual artificial neurons
which are themselves extremely simple
models of biological neurons
and
the deep and deep neural networks refers
to the fact that there are
layers of
these neurons sandwiched between the
input layer and the output layer and the
the greater the number of uh these
hidden layers the deeper the
deep neural network a bit of terminology
that we're going to encounter during the
discussion we're
potentially going to be speaking about
feed forward networks uh feed forward
simply refers to the fact that
information flows in
uh into the network on the input sides
and proceeds uh unidirectionally to
towards the output side
we will also encounter
convolutional neural networks these are
a particular architecture of deep neural
networks that have become extremely
successful in tasks like image
recognition
and we're the basis for many of the
early models of the visual system
we will potentially also
encounter recurrent neural networks
uh these are networks where the neurons
are not just exchanging information in
one direction but information can flow
bi-directionally between neurons or
between layers of neurons and such
networks
are
going to be useful for representing
temporal dynamics of neural activity
so
with that
i'm going to stop sharing my screen
and
just
yeah
and the way i would
like to start this panel discussion is
by posing
a
question to each of our panelists and
the questions are sort of designed to
bring our audience
up to date with the state of the art
with a little bit of history and
you know as briefly as possible so
so i'm going to start with uh dr lindsay
dr lindsay uh you have written a lot
about this in your book and in your
articles so could you could you talk a
little bit about how
the neuroscientific findings about the
primate visual system has influenced the
development of deep neural networks
maybe uh
from hubel and weasel's work with cats
to the new york hog neutron and to
modern day cnns
yeah uh so in the uh you know the late
50s and early 60s there's a lot of work
on the physiology of the visual system
particularly using cats as a model
organism to study that
and um huble and weasel in particular
discovered a few kind of basic features
of how cells um mostly in the primary
visual cortex of cats respond to images
and they went on to win the nobel prize
for for this another work that they did
um and so some of those basic features
are uh one that was kind of discovered
on accident by them is that these cells
respond primarily to just kind of
oriented lines so if there's just a
sharp line in uh
in the visual input that you're giving
to the cat you can find a cell that will
respond to that and it won't respond if
that line is at a different angle so
each cell has a preferred angle of
orientation that it responds to
and then also um this was kind of known
from from other visual areas but each uh
neuron has a preferred spatial visual
field so that line needs to be at a
particular spatial location in in the
visual field for that neuron to respond
to it so you have this kind of joint uh
spatial preference as well as preference
for orientation of the line
and
the class of cells which they called
simple cells
really had a tight spatial preference
whereas
a class of cells that they called
complex cells allowed for a little more
variability of exactly where that line
was still in a relatively small space
but not so precise
and they were able to deduce from this
some features of how this circuit must
work for example that it seemed like the
complex cells were basically getting
input from a handful of simple cells
each that had the same preferred
orientation but had slightly different
preferred spatial locations and that's
how you could create this kind of
spatial invariance while still having
this feature selectivity
and so um
uh an engineer who was working in um the
japanese broadcasting corporation uh
named fukushima heard about the work of
huble measle and um basically said well
those you know i can use those basic
principles to build an artificial visual
system if that's what the real visual
system is doing i can replicate that and
so he um
he made a model that is kind of the
basis of convolutional neural networks
now that involves a layer of cells that
look for simple patterns in an input
image and then a second layer of cells
that gets input from a handful of those
cells that all have the same feature
that they're looking for and therefore
creates this kind of spatial invariance
and
he also said in an interview that he was
waiting for huble and weasel to publish
what happens next like he thought you
know they'd go on to the next visual
area and then he could continue building
his model but that's not really where
they went with their research direction
so he decided to just kind of repeat
that process and add a few more layers
to the network so that you now had a
layer that was looking for patterns not
in the input image itself but in the
activity of the neurons in the layer
before and then again you do the spatial
and variance layer and then again you
look for patterns um and that's kind of
the basics uh the basis of what's now
convolutional neural networks because
you have a convolutional layer that
looks for patterns or the convolutional
filter that you run over the input image
where you identify a simple pattern in
the input image and then you have these
pooling layers that take in the activity
of a group of the cells in that
convolutional layer and then you repeat
and that's how you get these deep neural
networks so that's kind of the the basic
inspiration that led to the structure
that we use today
sorry i seem to have been muted all this
while uh apologies uh so uh thank you dr
lindsay for that answer uh dr malik a
question for you uh could you tell us a
little bit about the efforts at
developing computer vision before the
advent of cnns and how cnns have
impacted the field of computer vision
you've been in this field for a long
time so you've seen both sides of the
coin yeah sure so uh so first of all i
want to say that the computer vision
community has always been aware of
what's going on in neuroscience
and uh there have been models
uh way before uh you know 2012
which is the
the alex net movement which have used
knowledge of uh visual neuroscience
so in particular people had
the early stages of processing of
computer vision systems was always based
on some kind of
edge detection or orientation sensitive
filtering and models for that go back to
the 80s and so on so this is directly
inspired from uber and bezel that we
have filters which uh
run all over the image and these
correspond to orientation so we might
use gabor filters for example
and uh
the
the then the issue is what do you do so
that's basically like a model of v1 the
first stage of processing but we know
there are later stages of processing and
object recognition
or tasks like that come later in the
pathway so what do you do in between
and the
then one choice is that you have you
make this multi-layer neural network
in which case then the question is how
do you train it how do you find the
parameters of this right at the later
stages
and that's where there is a
that's where you have a fork in the road
where the computer vision community's
style was we are going to use standard
machine learning techniques support
vector machines was sort of particularly
popular in the
1990s and 2000s
and these
these techniques
lead to a network which is not very deep
because you just have these orientation
features these were called hog and shift
and so forth and then on top of that you
have your classification
and but the
the optimization problem was much more
approachable because it was a convex
optimization problem with guarantees
uh the alternative of course was the
connect architecture where you have
multiple layers and you train it using a
stochastic gradient descent
and those are the ideas that people like
yan likum had proposed
going back to 89 and there was always a
minor current on that and
but the mainstream in computer vision
stuck to
orientation in the first layer and then
after that
you use standard machine learning
techniques not neural network training
because of comfort with optimization
techniques
the breakthrough moment which came
with jeff hinton's group's work
uh was in 2012
and the new things which came to the
to the scene were
gpus which enabled compute at a large
scale
and very large data sets such as
imagenet
and the combination of that
enabled these networks to be trained at
a much bigger scale with
millions of parameters
and it turned out that
with that scaling
came improvement in performance
because the connects in the in a
previous decade
would not have
done as well as the sort of the more
standard computer vision combination
which is sort of hybrid of
half ideas from neuroscience half
ideas from standard machine learning
so that's i think the history of it now
once we got that we were all struck by
the
by this result there this alex net
result uh
it's being called the alex net moment
then after that what happened was that
basically we
we
we overcame our fear of non-convex
optimization problems and we learned to
love stochastic gradient descent
and
then over time the entire computer
vision community sort of started to use
this as the methodology right and uh and
and that's uh that that's what the the
big success was in the
in the
2010 uh
the entire 2010s
thank you that was a wonderful uh piece
of history um and uh
dr dicarlo i think uh
it would be great to hear from you about
how you started thinking about in the
late 2000s about using deep nets
to model the ventral visual stream for
what i think you call core object
recognition so if you could define that
for us a little bit and tell us about
the events that led to your
breakthroughs in the field around the
same time that alex net came out but it
was not at that point influenced by alex
net
jury neil yeah so just briefly on core
recognition so when i started like so i
was a grad student in the 90s or so and
and the question that was fascinating to
me was really a computer vision question
how human brains are able to categorize
objects even though under different
transformations
grace mentioned position but also
lighting pose other things you can still
say a cat is still a cat
and
that was that was a rallying question
for our field and we just defined core
recognition ultimately is about the
ability to do that very quickly it was
known from the work of molly potter and
others that you could identify objects
in group brief central glimpses of just
even a few hundred milliseconds you
could do quite accurately saying that
was a cat or not and so we operationally
defined core recognition as rapid that
is within a brief i brief glimpse um a
categorization problem that was a
biology version of what sort of what i
read is a lot of what was going on in
computer vision and categorization not
exactly but that was a biology version
so the context of of that was that was
that was a motivating question but but
just to back up a bit graces are and
chitanov already introduced the idea of
you know what are the networks that are
going to solve that and train as a
systems neuroscientist there was never a
time that we didn't think a deep neural
network would solve this i want to make
sure that context is clear because all
the textbooks were telling us this is
what hugo weasel said this was you know
grace gave that background very nicely
that and and it was just a matter of
which deep neural network was running so
we knew from the anatomy there was some
deep neural network v1 v2 v4 it
but we didn't know how it was
constructed in a detailed way
so and and and that was again that was
really following the line of work that's
already been described
and so
and fukushima was a leader in the sort
of initial models as already mentioned
my colleague tommy pojo here at mit kind
of made a next generation of models in
around 2000 or so
and then as jatunda mentioned gpu
started to come on the scene and folks
in my lab and others started to get
interested in using those to search
through larger families of such models
in the late 2000s and then it was again
in the early 2000s that real
breakthroughs happened on the computer
vision side of jitendra mentioned but on
the neuroscience side that that
breakthrough came from just starting to
instead of build those models bottom up
which we and others were doing like
what's the next thing that you should
add to it you started to actually say
let's make the models do something and
in our case it was make it do core
recognition in a deep network which
again we always took as the basic
architecture and then we found out that
when we did that that actually the
internals of those models started to
match the internals of the brain at a at
a certain single neuron level not
perfectly but far better than any models
before
um and really that sort of led to all
that that work was with by dan yemen's
and and others and and it's it was
really kind of surprising to us not
surprising an architectural sense but
just that that could that that it had
made dramatic leaps at that time right
around the time computer vision was
making leaps and i think those are not
uncorrelated facts
and that's led to now although probably
what we'll talk today which is still a
whole bunch of unanswered questions
about you know what way should we be
matching these networks with the brain
and how good is a good enough match and
does a match count as an understanding
and for me the question how do we get an
even better match how do we build the
next model guide to biology to build an
international those questions are now
still motivated
by that that history and the only thing
i would want to add a little bit at the
end here is that tundra mentioned
computer vision had these different
branches it was never to a biologist
like that was not surprising that these
would work it was only a question of
when they were so was sort of a
different take from the computer vision
community of course it had to be a deep
number because that's how all our
textbooks read to us
i hope that gives you some context yes
fascinating
and dr van paula you know you've been
thinking about uh modeling the brain at
a much higher uh level and so i was
wondering if you could tell us
how you see these efforts at modeling
the primate visual system in terms of
the overall ongoing effort and
understanding intelligence maybe in sort
of broad strokes for now and then we'll
come back for some details later
sure um um as a theoretical computer
scientist i just want to follow up and
say that i'm still scared of stochastic
and descent and non non-convex
optimization
um
but yeah neuroscience you know i've seen
this explosion of data collected using
amazing methods in the past decade
especially
the brain at many levels and we've seen
including individual active neurons
right so this rich
data and we understand really well how
individual neurons work and synapses
work and with the caveat that there are
over a thousand types
um and of course you know for centuries
psychologists have designed these
ingenious experiments to to to document
cognition
nevertheless the abilities of humans to
robustly learn generalize plan reason
tell stories
i mean they're both mundane but also
astounding and mysteries i think still
in fact what's missing is an overarching
theory of how the mind and i mean
loosely higher level cognition emerges
from the brain neurons and synapses as
as as nobel laureate richard axel put it
a couple of years ago
and here's a quote um we do not have
logic
for the transformation of neural
activity into thought and action
i view discerning this logic as the most
important future direction of
neuroscience
so in my view you know this is nothing
short of asking for a computational
explanation
you know a logic the brain is after all
a computational device now it has
well-defined changes of state and so
what are the rules and what phenomena
emerged from this provably
right um
so with uh with uh with uh computer
scientists uh
pioneering computer scientists christos
papa mithura and and our collaborators
we have an ongoing attempt at this and i
just want to mention it briefly to to
ground this discussion
and it's uh based on
decades of neuroscience
we call it the assembly calculus
its basic primitive is a neural assembly
which is a subset of neurons whose
coordinated firing
corresponds to the recognition or
thought of a concept you see an orange
you smell an orange if you think orange
this subset of neurons or most of them
fire
with very simple rules that are based on
widely accepted biological principles
synaptic plasticity homeostasis and
inhibition
one can show rigorously that stable
assemblies will form in response to
repeated presentation of stimuli these
assemblies can be recalled project to
different areas associated with each
other etc
i'll be happy to tell you more
please ask me later but going back to
vision
i think of it as a fantastic case study
as as as already mentioned uh by by the
other three it's directly inspired so
much of artificial neural networks and
vision research today neural circuits
convolution hierarchical processing
feedback sparse recovery etc but so much
more remains unexplained you know why do
we process images as a sequence is it
just because of computational
limitations of the brain or is there a
yet to be discovered better algorithm
that evolution has run into
how does the visual system run this 10
megapixel camera
and a gigabit bus and do all this
processing with 20 watts
you know really low power and of course
to me most interestingly how do humans
generalize you know when we see an
object it's much more you know we often
have or can tell a story about it
i can say can resonate do this and
that's maybe an unfair question but the
point is that there's so much more for
ai to still learn from the brain even in
the context of the visual system
i do believe though that the amazing
progress of artificial neural nets on
visual recognition tasks has so many
lessons for students of the brain
i mean jim's work is directly tying them
together
and these a nns in principle provide a
simulation testbed for many ideas
they've also demonstrated that a simple
rule-based system can learn to recognize
and classify a wide variety of data with
little domain knowledge
so i i think it's an exciting time for
both the visual system but also a more
general theory
thank you very much that sounds
extremely exciting um so i think
i would like to now just uh
throw a few things
up for discussion one of the key things
that would be nice to talk about is what
do we mean by
understanding when we say things like
we're building models of the human
visual system using deep neural networks
to understand the deep uh to understand
the visual system
what what does one mean by understanding
here uh
doesn't any one of you want to take that
dr carlo
sure i'll jump in this is of course been
an active topic of discussion in our our
fields broadly and i think there's the
way i the way in my head this goes
there's if you different communities
will have a different
sense of what they thought the answers
might look like what their form of the
understanding is cognitive scientists
would look at it one way neuroscientists
would look at it another way
theoretical physicists would look at it
a different way
that and they don't even agree on yet
what that would be
i think there's another version which is
just you can ask the question instead of
what makes each of those groups happy
which is almost a sociology question you
could ask a question of
what useful if you modeled a system that
mimics it you've used the word minix or
i see that in some of the chat
what use is that so use based
understanding and i think there's a
discussion to be had about you know what
could we do rather than talk about does
it count or not
turn the question to like what can you
do
with these models of the system that you
couldn't do without such models and i
think there are many examples of that
already on the table and there are more
that i think are going to be showing up
and we could brainstorm about what those
might be and i think that's the most
useful way to ground that and not get
dragged off into everybody's own
personal ideas of what this might be but
that's my that's my starting point on
that discussion
i'll let others chime in
dr lindsay you want to respond
um
uh i was going to say that uh
yeah i it is it's not agreed upon what
counts as understanding um but i do
think that there are some
there are some kind of concrete things
you can point to that some people argue
that this kind of approach can give you
and one is you know if you train a
network with a certain architecture on a
certain visual task and that gives you
the ability to predict real neural
activity whereas a different
architecture or a different task
wouldn't give you as good of an ability
then you are getting some evidence that
you've kind of hit the right
architecture and task you're finding a
task that you don't like uh object
recognition that it does seem like the
primate visual system is pretty tailored
to that must be a big part of what it
does if we're able to to get a good
model by training on that
um and you know you can try different
architectures on the same task and come
to similar conclusions i think the
results may be on that or less strong it
seems like a variety of architectures
can actually give us pretty good neural
productivity productivity um and then i
would other i would say you know from
like a more first person qualitative
perspective of
what these models can do for
understanding um so i was an early grad
student when i heard about jim's work
with dan yeemans using um at the time
not trained with backprop but these kind
of deep neural networks um getting good
uh scores on predicting neural activity
and that had i mean that changed my
research direction it changed how i
thought about how i wanted to study the
visual system because prior to that i
kind of had this sense really based on
you know work from the 50s and 60s by
hubel and weasel that you could come up
with the thing that each visual area was
tuned to like v1 is tuned to orientation
and you can put orientation on the
x-axis and you can put the response of
the neuron on the y-axis and you'll get
a tuning curve and so in my mind it was
like okay so what is and we had some
guesses about like v2 had certain
properties it was tuned to and i was
interested in v4 and thinking about what
is v4 tuned to so the sense that i
should be able to put a single thing on
the x-axis like maybe it's a somewhat
complicated function of the input image
but i should be able to put a single
thing on the x-axis and have a word that
describes it and say that's what v4 is
tuned to and thinking of it instead as
this deep neural network that's trained
to do this task that you know what
matters is that the inputs get to the
right outputs and that kind of thing it
just made that seem like less of a
reasonable research question like why
should there be a word that i can use to
describe what the cells in v4 are
responding to the responding to some
intermediate shapes that are necessary
for whatever the network is trying to do
and so i think that shift in what we're
thinking about and you know how we
formulate research questions can come
from just putting a different focus on
the system rather than the single neuron
tuning focus to this kind of population
hierarchy
think about the actual task in its full
complexity uh to focus in our research
questions on that kind of thing
um
anyone else wants to jump in and say
something about understanding
i'm sure sorry go ahead
yeah i i would like to but could you
show that slide that i sent you yes
yeah
so i'm going to share this let me see
how do i do this now
yeah is that visible
yeah perfect thank you
okay so uh i i want to uh
sort of take the discussion to a
slightly higher level you know
so
we have always struggled with what are
the
what are the levels of understanding in
biology
and in the in the context of vision the
most famous is uh what david maher
described you know in his book back in
1980 or so
which is the three levels of
understanding and
he was very clear about this because
that was one way in which
people who are
in computer vision and people who are in
neuroscience and people who are in
cognitive science could talk and not be
confusing each other
okay
and he said that we should try to
understand something at three levels
there's a level of the computational
theory which is what are the fundamental
constraints which underlie the task so
for example stereopsis is about
correspondence and triangulation and so
on then there might be an algorithmic
level
and then there might be an
implementation
and those were the three levels and and
they should not be confused an answer at
one level is not an answer at the other
level
and he didn't emphasize learning which i
mean in hindsight we can think of was a
was one of the things he should have
emphasized but he did
but i like to point out that even 20
years before david mar
there was a there's a there was nikko
tinbergen and he's a ethologist he
studies
animals in their in their
ecological habitat in their niches and
so forth and he's a nobel prize winner
from 1973.
and
they were similar there was similar
confusion in that area of biology
which was basically people talking past
each other because they were talking at
different levels of explanation
and i think those four levels that he
described those four questions that he
described are totally relevant to our
discussion today so that's why i made up
the slide
so first uh there's a level of so
there's the higher level distinction
between how and why so the how causation
how does the behavior get elicited what
pathways within the animal are involved
so that's a pretty mechanistic question
about layers of the neural network and
how some information is being
transformed from what is at the retina
the photoreceptors to the stage where we
can say aha
the animal knows that there is a cat
there is a development process which we
can think of both in as a cognitive
sciences and as a neuroscience question
how do children learn how do they
acquire knowledge of the world how do
they cannot be born knowing about
having the ability to detect toyota
prioses but somehow
over their first couple of years of
experience
with the world interacting with objects
and and so on and so forth this system
gets tuned up so there's a cognitive
aspect and a neuroscience aspect to it
right so we can talk about how these
neural networks acquire their weights
okay then there is a
third question which is evolution or the
phylogeny question which is uh how did
this develop over time this is not
something that maybe computer scientists
care about but for a biologist this is a
valid question how did what are the
differences in visual systems over uh
over the
last 500 million years
then there's a final question which is
actually of great concern to people in
computer vision and computational
modeling which is
how does this behavior
help the organism and why does it work
in that sense so for example there is
statistics of the world we live in
this makes for certain inferences to be
possible for example
by lab most of the objects we deal with
have opaque surfaces in them
if we instead lived in a fluid where
everything was a varying density
you would kind of need a different kind
of vision system and the processes that
we have developed would not work uh
effectively
right we have a ground plane we have
objects which are on the ground plane
there's a bias towards vertical because
of gravity i mean uh
the psychologist gibson back in the
1950s pointed out that
essentially the kind of physics we need
is not generic physics not the physics
which work at the works at the scale of
atoms as well as at galaxies but physics
at the scale of the
of the of the of the organism so the
units are meters and seconds for a good
reason and for a different organism it
might be different and actually there is
someone called foreign who talked about
this earlier in terms of what is
what is the
um wealth of a tick for example
anyway i'm i i may have gone on too long
now but my point is that there are
different levels of explanation and then
some of these
uh questions
uh replicate themselves in in when we
talk about computational modeling but
computational modeling uh
so so we but
they're all interesting in some sense
thank you very much um
i guess this leads us to you know
the question about how do we move on or
if and indeed i think some computational
neuroscientists are already doing this
uh
you know the previous models have mostly
been kind of feed forward cnns uh that
have been modeling the
ventral visual stream
so how do we kind of
move on from that particular technology
to more
you know to model the
visual system with more fidelity so what
what is it going to involve
any thoughts on that
in terms of the actual technology that
we'll need to develop or that's already
there
dr lindsay
i think gemma is raising his hand oh
okay sorry
oh it's okay grace if you want to go
first i i can chime in
um
yeah i think i would make a meta point
because sometimes this
gets overlooked because so much of the
work of of looking at deep neural nets
in comparison to the brain is about
looking at feed forward convolutional
neural networks trained on a specific
object recognition task using supervised
training with back propagation like
that's what a lot of the models we're
looking at are and so people assume that
the framework of using deep neural
networks to understand the visual system
requires all of those facts and then
they have problems with that because you
know a purely feed-forward system that
we know is not the truth of biology
there's recurrence at all layers in the
visual system and uh supervised training
on this single task is you know that's
not the entirety of what the visual
system does and all of these things and
so just to make the meta point that
you can still work within this framework
of defining an architecture and training
it on a visual task but you can
substitute out or add in all kinds of
different components that you think are
relevant to capturing the the biological
reality for whatever question you're
you're interested in um so yeah so i'm
doing a project that includes looking at
recurrent convolutional neural networks
now and you can just add in recurrent
connections and train the network you
know you can you can do a little bit of
whatever you want if you can write down
something that's that's mostly
differentiable you can train the network
to do the task and you can you know use
different images and define the tasks
differently and all those kinds of
things so i don't even know if there's
so much you know at least for
a lot of the low-hanging fruit of what
we're missing i don't know that there's
so much technological development that
needs to happen i think a lot of the
basics are there
it's just a matter of kind of trying
things out and figuring out what kind of
insights you can have by adding certain
details because you don't want to just
add details for details sake you want to
have a sense of the computational role
of the details you're adding and you
know study an appropriate task that will
reveal those so you can actually get it
something useful that can be true in
both the model and the brain you know
for what those details add
dr carlo you had some thoughts
yeah i mean i i told i completely agree
with grace's points here that you know
in some sense the game has shifted
towards you have architectural details
whether it's macro architecture details
of the neurons themselves or recurrence
that that's a space of things you can
change you have
you have the task space which she's
mentioned a couple times which is of
course an exciting area and connects to
a lot of interest computer vision tasks
naturally and then you have
you have this optimization function
how are you going to optimize the thing
actually mentioned things that are
differentiable it doesn't have to be
differentiable but that also relates to
the the thing that jitendra said about
kind of development so that that's the
biology version of the development side
i i think it's still interesting to
discuss if we were to ground this to
make it a little more provocative even
just take the how question from tim
bergen that digital gave you think of
these models as they're a description of
how
the the normative frame with the task
that lindsey's giving is that provides a
frame of like uh oh it's it was this was
the reason it's theirs to do object
recognition that's probably not right
but it is something it's not fully right
but it's something that mode it's
something you take from that prior work
but just the how question i think
there's it's it's it's there's a thought
experiment of what is the answers to how
what should they look like
and you know this comes back to even if
you get all the detail you get the
details right you optimize you get you
get a copy of the system and that's your
how answer and that's kind of where
we're headed and the knobs we turn are
the ones that grace described they're
not going to be the v4 those color knobs
they're going to be these other three
knobs but i think it would ask kirby to
be provocative it's probably not going
to be the case that knob a causes x and
knob b causes why those knobs are going
to be inadequate in the same way that
the original knobs of b1 and b2 does
this and that are also inadequate
they're going to interact in complex
ways and so even though that's our
current mental crutch i think it's going
to be you know there'll be another wave
where that is like it's not you're not
going to make clean inferences on any of
those knobs is my suspicion so maybe i'm
looking too far ahead but i i think
that's uh i think that's something to
keep in mind from a prospective point of
view that that that may feel i think
it's an improvement but it's not it's
not the end and i guess one other point
i'd like to add is like these models are
now useful like george box said
that some all models are wrong and some
are useful and these are useful and
they're obviously wrong and we're all
talking about what ways do we make them
better
and i think that the thing that that we
haven't touched on maybe grace implied
that well we have all the techniques on
that on the build side we might
but on the aligning with biology it's
still a very hard task to do that in a
standardized way and that's where a lot
of effort at least in my lab and others
are trying to go right now is how would
we even know if we had the right answer
you know that that's a hard question i
think could be discussed and it gets
back to what understanding needs so i'll
stop there and let others try to
draw you have a computer scientist
perspective on this
i'm sure yeah i'll try to
um so besides uh
rnns which were discussed nicely
i mean the brain has lots of recurrent
connections there are some very exciting
advances in machine learning such as the
efforts to do these
deep neural nets with limited
supervision
or or limited amount of
labeled data
and people are now able to use
pre-trained
uh classifiers with very little
relatively little training at the at the
extreme layers and reproduce
state-of-the-art uh accuracies
um
so there is progress there and that
maybe this is going to be very useful
for the brain also
now um i i do have to get back a little
bit and this answers maybe one of the
questions in the chat also or in the q a
namely what do we mean by understanding
here i mean the usual bar for science
would be a succinct model
that explains all the data we have and
makes predictions
well here you know we know so little
about the brain that i would be very
happy with what people are doing namely
to try to reproduce the brain's
abilities in in you know in simulation
or in silico
um so
and the point here i want to make is
that we don't understand why artificial
neural networks work
at this scale even at object recognition
and nobody has been able to convince me
about why they actually work or what
context they will work
so given that even for an explicit model
where we know exactly what every piece
is and what the algorithm that's running
is we still can't explain it
i mean it's
uh i
uh uh
we're we're miles away from uh from
trying to
get the model at the usual bar of
science so reproducing it fantastic play
with all the knobs all the knobs you
want to yeah
and and uh i think this has been brought
up a couple of times but uh the whole
process of learning itself uh you know
these models so far we're not really
modeling necessarily the learning
process is that also going to be an
uh
sort of path forward to try and
understand how the brain got to where it
is
oh yeah i mean that's it that's a very
interesting question
you know
i'm sorry i assumed you were
pleased yeah
i mean the brain itself i mean has to be
understood
with in the context of evolution right
certainly explains the variety of
organisms
and their sensory
mechanisms
just in the visual visual system as i
learned from bruno while thousands
jumping spiders to owls to primates you
know such complex and highly
sophisticated visual systems and so one
could view evolution as a matter
learning process right where actually
from generation to generation you're
doing gradient descent on the parameters
of a population the parameters being the
genetic distribution
so from this perspective it's really
striking that the abilities that we
encounter today
um evolution was able to hit within a
small number of iterations something
like 10 to the 12.
um
and and uh
yes so we won't understand how it's
being done we know very well that it's
unlikely that gradient descent or back
propagation is happening in the brain
there is some kind of synaptic update
and maybe there is a rule that's been
learned or the brain learns to learn
rules but these are these are i think as
open-ended as
as
as as any of the current specific
approaches yeah
i
what about modeling that goes beyond the
uh ventral visual stream are there
challenges there
oh absolutely uh i mean um
uh let's think about one of um
perhaps the most unique human ability
language
right uh uh um
what's happening there
it's it's particularly fascinating
because this this ability started only
about 100 000 years ago
and it seems to be adapted perfectly to
the brain's uh
strengths the brain itself has a human
brain hasn't changed much in this period
and so uh
how do we understand language and i
think i don't think it's a separate
system i think really these questions
you're asking about learning to learn
or
the fact that we process
images sequentially more like stories
than like
paintings is uh is
is is linked to language and our ability
to to to to string together
um uh stories so
um the the amazing progress that's
happening now in machine learning in
deep learning where they're able to
get
pre-trained models to
produce
amusing stories if not coherent ones
is is is very fascinating and i think
there's there's much more to down that
line
dramatic
yes uh so uh i have a few things to say
uh i think uh we need to
uh it's good to look at what these
networks can't do what the current
models can't do and let's start with the
core with uh with the object recognition
task and then move out from there
so
the object recognition
task the kinds of models which are
popular in computer vision
they they have certain characteristics
they are actually much deeper than what
their brain has their feet forward with
like 50 layers or 100 layers as opposed
to the pathway from the retina to it
which might be just seven synapses
okay but has recurrence instead
second characteristic is that we use way
too many training examples
so the
image net has a thousand categories each
with a thousand examples or more
okay there has been there have been
arguments made that for example when a
child grows up in the in in his or her
visual world there might be relatively
few objects but the child sees them much
more intensely because the child has
exposure to the object in its 3d aspects
so from different directions you get to
see that object and that gives you a
much better training signal
so these are two significant differences
we can learn humans can learn from very
few examples but we learn with them
in a sort of 3d setting
and
as opposed to needing these very very
large number of examples we managed to
do it with
a far shallower network but with
recurrence
in my mind these are very profitable
directions to pursue these will be
helpful for
computer vision and i think they are
kind of central to the to to to
biological vision
moving further out i think recognition
is of course not the only visual task
uh in fact in the earlier in uh sort of
other animals it's it's it's much more
about sort of moving about navigation
locomotion you know visual guidance of
various kinds of actions so
i feel that the essence of intelligence
is in the sensory motor loop
and
we
we we don't tackle that because the
kinds of data sets that we in computer
vision provide people are all static
data sets
but this is not the right thing this is
not the right setting
for intelligence we really want a kind
of simulation environments and a more
active setup
and on language i would just disagree
with santosh i think language is a much
much later stage and it i think are
under it
at least to me it's scientifically much
more profitable to focus on on the
sensory motor loop
the kinds of transfer systems that
learning that has been shown in these
you know systems like birth and so forth
in the language setting i consider these
to be quite misleading the kind of
language they have is completely
ungrounded it has the people that the
systems can translate from english to
french but they do not know what any of
the words correspond to as a sensory
motor entity so i feel that that that
it's a very useful engineering
discipline but i'm not sure if the
current language systems
are
operating in a way which will give us
much insights into the brain is i do
have faith in what we are doing in
vision i feel that there is a connection
there language i'm not sure
i think i think if we're not careful
we'll spend an hour talking about gpt3
now so i'm going to move the
conversation somewhere else uh you
already preempted dr malik with my
question about limitations so that's
fantastic maybe we can talk about uh
applications like how
these things could potentially be used
so it's not just because you want to
understand the brain that people are
building these models but you know i
know that dr dicarlo's
you know quest for intelligence effort
is also thinking about applications so
could you talk about how
these models could potentially be put to
use
oh neil yeah i guess that's for me so if
we're just going to stick the vision
right so again i think there's an
interesting discussion of beyond vision
and i have to also chime in and i
totally agree with that point to tundra
made is that vision is much more than
recognition and i think
i think that guessing at the next task
to put in is sort of and that's to
lindsay's point of like putting those in
is a good forward model exploration
direction but in terms of applications i
mean it's sort of you know i'm way to
think about this is what can we do with
the models of primate vision that we
have today
that we couldn't that we couldn't do
with the models of fukushima right or
like get back to the historical context
like okay these models are better
matched so what is that what is what
power does that grant us and you know
that's useful to think through because
then it allows you to think about what
the next generation of models what new
powers they might
grant us wherever those models came from
whether they're from better task choices
or better architecture or better
optimization
and so if you think about the models as
they stand right now for primate vision
their models that take pixels
and turn them into neural patterns which
turn them into behaviors
right so why does that matter because
that that model says your control points
on those models are pixels neurons and
behaviors there's no there's no
statement about if you gave me a you
know a gene modification in my brain
what that would do
models don't engage yet on that they
could someday but they don't yet it's
okay so then you think about that you
can start to think about what can i do
with the models today again today's
models that i couldn't do with
fukushima's mouth and one of the things
that we've already shown you can do is
the models allow you to construct pixel
patterns that will set the neurons into
states that you desire now why you
desire them that you will set that
acquired that's a values question but if
i say i want a high level of the mod the
neural network in the brain of the
primate to look a certain way certain
neurons to be on certain areas to be off
the models allow us to work back through
to construct the pixel patterns that
will cause that to happen to the extent
the models are correct and that is
pointing out again that use all use base
applications are kind of depend on the
control knobs of the models and so pixel
control is something that we as humans
have built up a lot of commodity
hardware to actually already deliver
we're doing it all right now which means
that we don't need you know tubes in
your head or pharmaceuticals in your
bloodstream
there are now new ways to modify your
visual system activity just by the
knowledge that these models effectively
contain the understanding that they
embed
similarly there's they allow us to think
about if we activated neurons within
those models what would be the change in
our behavior or our perception if you
will and that sort of towards brain
possible brain machine interfaces that
we couldn't have built without such
models and again i'll just sort of say
those are sort of the things that models
can do today and guidance and those are
work that's ongoing but we could talk
about the models of the future we might
like to build that go beyond just in
pixels to neurons to to behavior which
would then open up other possible
applications or we could extend these in
other areas like languages already
mentioned and then the same things would
apply how do i speak to you in a way
that you perceive me faster than you
could for instance than you currently do
now those are examples of what these
kind of models should be able to grant
in terms of applications just a couple
of examples and of course there's the ai
versions like chitandra is a computer
vision person as these models if they're
better they might lead to computer
vision applications more robustness
faster learning he's given some examples
of that but i'll leave it there because
i'm sure others have thoughts on
application uses as well
i actually want to hear from the
computer vision perspective because it's
been my sense that aside from the basic
you know convolutional architecture and
influence that came many decades ago i
don't know that adding recent biological
detail to convolutional neural networks
like in the past few years has led to
practically better models you can add
biological details that make the network
better at something but there's usually
a non-biological way to do that that
will make it better faster less data
less computationally efficient or more
computationally efficient that kind of
thing it seems like maybe the influence
has come at the more psychological level
like people add attention to models now
but it's not really based on what we
understand about the neural basis of
attention it's more the concept of
attention and what people assume it's
for um so yeah i wonder are there
examples where like specific biological
details have been added lately that have
actually made the models practically
better for real world applications
or dr malik
uh okay maybe i will take this so uh
so of course there is no one computer
vision
approach because
there are as many researchers there's
there'll be as many
approaches so i personally am in the
camp where i look
a lot to neuroscience and cognitive
science for inspiration and uh
it turns out that uh i mean there's a
lot of
work going on on
like looking in real detail at what's
what are the competitions happening at
the dendritic level and so on right now
now large i regard that as kind of
irrelevant to what i do right now
because it's we we our current
abstractions are good enough and for for
for the moment
i feel that uh there is one particular
topic that we explored
which was the issue of recurrence and
and so forth
and here it turns out that there's an
interesting reason why we didn't get
value out of using recurrence uh which
of course is there in uh in neuroscience
and that's the following
that we can we have recurrence but we
don't want to have a lot of we don't
want to take
many many uh cycles of that recurrence
because the decision has to be made
available in 150 milliseconds or
whatever so therefore the number of
recurrence rounds that you can have are
relatively few in which case you can
take uh
that network and we can unroll it to be
just a feed forward network with say
three times the depth
okay
and now technologically we can therefore
emulate it by a network which is deeper
now in fact you have more power because
you could have different weights
at the different in the different copies
of the network
and uh so so so so this is i think part
of the reason why
this direction has not been so
profitable from a purely
uh computer vision application point of
view but scientifically that's different
right scientifically you don't get to
make a 50 layer network because if the
network has seven layers you've got
seven layers
and you know jim and i have had uh
joint grants before and we have one now
and we'll end up debating this question
repeatedly which is that
unfortunately from the scientific point
of view but
very sensibly for
an engineer
there is a slightly different solution
here now
uh i do think that there is a lot of
inspiration from cognitive science
possible cognitive science and visual
perception so the abilities of human
visual system to deal with variation and
pose variation in lighting
uh i mean some of the processes of child
development where uh
stereotypical motion comes first then
stereo then the ability to see depth and
pictorial cues i think these give us a
lot of guidance
in terms of our architecture and
strategies in my mind this journey is
really
at a very early stage there's
periodically hype that oh yeah we are 90
percent have solved the problem so
forget about 90 percent of ai i don't
think we are at 90 percent of vision i
think we are at like 20 percent of
vision and vision is the most understood
part of the brain and the most
successful part of ai as well but it's
only a 20
success that we have so far
so maybe at the
you know we can now move on to questions
because we've come to the end of our
hour it's been amazing uh time has just
gone by so quickly um i would like to
ask prasad
in calvin hall at the simons institute
to see if there's anyone there who wants
to ask a question before we take
questions from our online audience
questions here
so i i had a question
um
so about the neural system of
cats and and organisms
is it
it's difficult to reproduce them but or
even understand what individual neurons
are doing but is it true that we can
make a correspondence between many
different cats and identify the same
kind of a function of or same neuron in
different cats
meaning uh is it the case that what the
neurons are doing also depends on how
they're trained because i would imagine
if we trained a neural network on
different data there would be different
neurons doing different things
and so how reproducible is it
uh across different cats um
i could try to take that um yeah so the
basic properties of like there are cells
that have preferred orientations that
you find across individual cats you find
it in monkeys uh you find it across a
lot of different species especially at
primary visual cortex and the first the
first area that's doing visual
processing in the cortex
that those classes exist you can't have
like this cell is exactly equal to that
cell kind of thing but you can predict
in advance what the broad response
properties will be
um and then uh
i you know i think the there is a sense
that as you go um deeper into the
hierarchy and you get to kind of these
more object selective areas like i t i
would assume there's more individual
variability that might have to do more
with um you know the life history of the
the individual and also you can get
variability in the primary visual cortex
if you do very extreme things like raise
a cat in an environment that only has
vertical lines that's going to
completely change the distribution of
preferred orientations that that cat has
so during certain critical periods of
development you can have a strong impact
of the environment on the individual
animals but assuming a normal
environment there are certain properties
that are pretty conserved across
individuals
and then when you're getting into kind
of
specialized regions that probably show a
little bit more um more variability
that's that's based on the animal's
history
thank you
i i think we have no more questions from
the hall we'll take questions over zoom
okay um so
there's a question about attention i
think it was partly addressed uh already
but let me just uh say it out
cognitively speaking attention plays a
very important role in vision what has
been and will be the role of the
neuroscientific understanding of
attention in designing computational
models
anyone
i have a lot of feelings about this
i studied attention during my phd in the
visual system and yes as i kind of
mentioned earlier there is
attention in some of these models
there's different definitions of
attention in machine learning within
machine learning there's a few different
things that are called attention and
then they have a whole separate you know
we use attention in entirely different
ways in neuroscience and in psychology
um so
it's an important thing that we use
especially um kind of to
i i view it partly as
to specialize a general purpose system
we have our visual system that can do a
lot of different things but on the fly
you might want it to be really good and
really quick at a specific subtask and
so you want to deploy attention to
something in particular
um and so i think you know if you want
to create a visual system that works
like a human visual system you're going
to have to include in touch and part of
it um but the way that it's currently
being used in machine learning i think
has
somewhat limited overlap i mean again
it's it's a high level inspiration but
the actual details of how it's
implemented don't exactly align with
what we know of how attention modulates
neurons
biologically but they don't have to
because you know engineers want to build
a system that works well and that they
can train and so they define attention
in a way that that works for them and
that's totally fine um but it is a
little bit different uh at the current
time and i i wrote a whole review
article on this so that's why i i'm
riled up right
right dr dekala you had anything to add
to that
uh well i agree with all of what was
said i just the only thing i would add
is first as to point out that that word
there is
there's no intentional
okay the word attention has been reified
so in biology there's a potential
phenomena
and those are the things you need a
model to explain but unfortunately the
field has not done a good job of of
specking when something has achieved
those phenomena or not they've instead
assumed there is a magical mechanism
called attention which isn't even agreed
upon what that would be let alone hand
it to an engineer so you can't blame uh
computer vision engineers or ai
engineers for saying we're gonna
use attention which becomes a cover word
for anything that sort of has a state
dependent modulation which is still
useful but now we're doing we're engaged
in cog and neural branding and that is i
think not helpful to either field and
but i put that more on the cognitive
scientists than the ai engineers because
if we would define our terms and specify
that they wouldn't be in that situation
um but i think that sort of creates more
confusion than progress at the interface
but there could be a space to do that
well and i think i i'm sorry grace i
haven't read the review but i'm sure it
probably points in the right direction
of how that could be made more
productive than it has been
um
thank you uh there's a provocative
question here directed at professor
malik uh so it says professor malik
mentioned that the state-of-the-art
language models are ungrounded isn't the
same true of vision models
i mean what do you mean vision models
are not grounded i i mean
my definition of grounding is i can
take a camera and i can point to
some scene
and my model will say that is a cat
and that they can do so in that sense
they are grounded the the when we talk
about uh unground lack of grounding in
language models i'm referring to
uh just for being specific say a
transformer model like bird which is
being used to translate from say english
to french
right so it will translate the word cat
from english to french but it will not
know what a cat is in the world
it does not know i mean there's been a
lot of work which has tried to expose
that these models don't have quote a
deeper understanding of the world they
are in this language space but they
don't connect to the
world so the language is supposed to be
a mirror of the world but it is not a
mirror of the world
whereas our visual systems are so our
computer vision systems are so
i completely feel uh that i'm not guilty
of this and the computer vision
community has got this right
in vision and in robotics you don't get
to be not grounded
we are always
grounded dr vampire any thoughts on that
um
yeah i i want to go back one step to the
attention question just because um
uh
just as an operational definition if i
think of attention as what part of the
visual field i'm paying attention to
which we know
brains do very well in some sequence
they don't process the whole thing
together
uh
i wonder if that that
and i'd be very curious to hear from the
rest remaining panelists so in when you
know when i when when babies learn say
to read or toddlers letters it's not
that they see the image right away
somebody's showing them the strokes in a
sequence
and my
i wonder if this this sort of
serialization
uh actually helps you make your
recognition system much more robust
so that now if i put in other variations
such as light and 3d and squiggly lines
and so on
there is a higher level element of
sequence that's still preserved and
therefore you're much more robust to
transformations
so so
maybe attention is key and it's
certainly it
seems to be relatively
less modeled in computer vision systems
or sequence
um
yeah
whereas
this sort of attention and sequence is
critical to
to prediction in a sequence such as
language so so so there might be
something quite fruitful there
even if it's very very early days for
for actual language tasks
all food for thought someone has a
question about
learning
if backprop is not the answer for the
brain what is
we haven't really talked about backdrop
that much but
yeah so these you know
maybe someone can take that it
kind of speaks to the whole question of
how did the brain get to where it is
i'll be happy to start off on that i
mean plasticity is what has been
established as what
solidly you know there's
the simplest version being heavy and
plasticity where if uh if both endpoints
of a synapse fire within a short
interval of each other then the weight
of the synapse goes up
and
the question is whether this rule is
sufficient to learn uh
uh productively to to generalize
and
now there's a growing body of rigorous
evidence
including in this in models of
assemblies of neurons
that at least for uh simple learning
tasks uh plasticity actually suffices
uh you don't need back propagation which
seems hard to have to implement
there are variations of course of
plasticity i mean uh the books on
therapy neuroscience have lists many
different variations that are closer to
what's happening at individual synapses
and and
the many different kinds but the
question of finding alternatives to back
propagation which really needs feedback
from much later layers to earlier layers
could be very productive not just to get
closer to biology but to find
better more robust methods
in in ai you mean
yes yeah
yeah
um dr de carl you you've been thinking
about this question also right about how
the learning mechanisms learning to
model uh
the learning process itself is is that
something
that's going to be more difficult than
what has gone on so far
yeah i mean i i have a lot to say on
this fight i think i just i think it'd
be good for us to at least get on the
same page i mean of course every
synapse has changed their struck weight
structure so everybody so the brain is
plastic in that sense but you know it's
like saying an iphone has transistors
and then how does an iphone work that's
the leap right so
just because you have plastic synapses
how do you structure the plasticity in
the network so that you get improved
performance like how does the system do
that now we get into spaces of back
props semi-backprop you know
unsupervised
all the different variants you might
imagine so that's where the action is on
the model side but as you pointed out
already satoshi there's always an
assumption that humans somehow are
learning this all post-natal
remember learning can be extrapolated
over all of evolution so the birth state
is already like you come out in the
language of hardware computer you come
out like a nice asics chip
you don't need to be a big plastic gpu
you're already well configured you know
that's how we think of the retinol right
there's lots of parts of our visual
system that already are pre-built
and there is no learning and we as
humans tend to highlight the parts we're
really good at really and we just ignore
the parts we're really bad at so we have
a bet a wrong perspective of mapping
that we think we're more plastic than we
actually are so so but i think all that
being said we certainly do learn things
postnatally studying that is a lot
harder than studying especially in
humans and non-human primates studying
that postnatal development is much
harder
than it is and then studying adult um
functional processes which is where the
more progress has been made um but and
but that being said i think these are
very interesting things to study whether
they will unlock new ai things or even
deep insights into biology eventually
they will but
for the biology side we have to figure
that out um i just don't think it um
how can i say it it hasn't been
again i have that bias for vision that
people they seem to think the system is
learning it a lot and i have a different
bias that it's just understanding how it
works
without a lot of learning gives you is
already is sort of the first move to
make and the question is are we ready to
shift to the other problem and maybe
maybe a bit so
um but i don't know how that will
generalize outside the vision system
i'll sort of admit i'm sort of naive i
don't know how we would even ground that
many of the others on the call may have
some sense of
how did how did if and how to do that
i'm sorry i said a lot of things but i
hope that that might i'm trying to be
provocative a bit here and motivate some
discussions
has anyone been energized to respond to
that or we can move on to another
question i i do have a question that i
think uh
i've heard dr malik speak about this
elsewhere so this would be a nice one
for you uh do you think current ai
algorithms cnn rnns which we talked
about are sufficient to get to
intelligence and understand the
processing of the brain or
and we just need more compute power or
do we need better algorithms yet to be
discovered not cnns and rnns
uh
i think i mean i i think i i said
earlier that we are like 20 of the
journey
now uh does that uh now in a certain
trivial sense we could say oh
well it could perhaps all be achieved
with cnns one day right it's like all
computing can be achieved by turing
machines right so
but that doesn't mean that we haven't
had to do
you know uh you know something like 80
years of work since turing machines so
uh to me uh
the important question really is how
much of the vision problem is solved
and in my mind more of it is unsolved
than has been solved and it's because
we have made progress on certain narrow
tasks like recognition which are very
important and very technologically
useful
but uh
like if you consider
an agent acting in the world perceiving
and then
interacting with the world there's a
long way to go and of course that vision
connects to
cognition and language and so forth and
that's where we get into issues of
concepts again a long way to go so
so
whether it will be just current
architectures or new architectures
i i think we
it may be even that there is we are
actually several architectures will be
equivalent so currently there is a game
going on where people are replacing
convenience by transformers
right lots of papers are being written
on this theme
interestingly and and the basic claim is
we can do as much as trans as connects
and one percent better
what's interesting to me is that the
performance of the con nets and the
transformers is so similar that is to me
the interesting fact which is that on
imagenet they're both around 85. maybe
on cocoa they're both around 60
and so on and so forth
okay which shows that it's actually some
kind of limitation of the data and the
broad strategy that is
uh and we have these two different ways
of code skinning the cat
thank you i wanted to to make a comment
about that question though because the
question of oh can we use the the
architectures and the learning rules
that we have and we just need to add
more data i think you can only answer
that in terms of will that get you to
kind of adult level performance because
we already kind of acknowledge that we
need too much data to replicate how much
data humans use in learning so if you
want to replicate kind of the whole
development of an individual human then
the answer can't be more and more data
because then you're already violating
kind of the constraints that we put in
by saying you're trying to recapitulate
the whole development
you could argue that evolution you know
means that you had way more data as a
species but for certain things that's
clearly not what's at play like when
you're learning a specific language it's
not because evolution gave you so much
data on that specific language so i
think you can only say you can only
argue that more data is all we need if
you're just trying to get to some
endpoint of a certain behavioral metric
but you can't argue that more data will
save you if you're trying to
recapitulate the whole development
process
well i think we're really coming to the
end of our uh allotted one and a half
hours so i would
like to kind of bring this to a close by
asking each one of you to maybe spend a
minute giving us your final thoughts on
this topic
either on things that we've already
talked about or something that we didn't
touch upon uh we can start in reverse
order this time maybe dr impala you can
go first
you're on mute
sorry um uh yes absolutely yeah uh i i i
like uh jim's distinction of course of
prenatal versus postnatal and i can see
that in the visual system
maybe much of the
network was already set up by evolution
and as far as evolution is concerned
sure use whatever
optimization method
seems to work best but there is
undisputably some learning that happens
postnatally especially in humans and
observably so and i think this needs
an explanation based on mechanisms that
we can agree on
are observed in the brain so and which
could be quite fruitful because that's
where a lot of intelligence seems to
come in beyond core object recognition
um
one point i want to make in closing is
from my background as a theoretical
computer scientist um how primitive we
are i mean the traditions here um i i
already mentioned that we don't
understand why
object recognition or artificial neural
networks in general as soon as you move
away from the convex space work as well
as they do i mean it's totally open
and perhaps this is part of the reason
is is sort of a limitation or burden of
how theoretical work is conducted today
you know the most desired explanation
is the following form it says algorithm
a works on any input x using at most y
examples and then at most z times that
would be great right i mean that's how
classical machine learning algorithms
guarantees go
we can't do this for deep learning and
maybe
you know it's it's actually intractable
to concern there are there is some
evidence that it is
however you know
biological learning is intimately tied
to the environment
you know we learn in our environments
through evolution but also in lifetime
and so rather than worst case
intractability you know maybe adapting
to natural environments and working well
in those and those specific ones is
actually tractable and efficient how so
is is to be answered
and maybe part of the answer i think
would be for theoreticians to move away
from you know sort of mathematically
nice models of the environment like iid
data and gaussians
uh to actually modeling the environment
in more useful productive ways and it
would be great to get input from
cognitive scientists and biologists and
people on the interface like like people
on this panel about how to do that most
usefully
thank you
dr malik your final thoughts
yes so
i think
there's a core enterprise which is
people
from neuroscience and cognitive science
backgrounds talking with uh people in ai
computer vision robotics and so forth
and uh
i think uh i i really believe that
that's a very profitable interaction and
uh
uh
most of the time it will not pan out but
in the few times when it pans out it is
a big deal
right so like i think the content story
is an example of it panning out and it
being a big deal there are a whole lot
of other settings where it hasn't panned
out but that's fine
i think that uh in uh
we we need ideas from wherever we can
and
and we
we we should be open to that
since this is a panel at the simon's
institute which is a institute of
theoretical computer science i want to
say i'll i will just
for whatever reason choose to expound on
that on how theory can help so there's
certainly a theory needed to
uh to to explain the success of deep
learning right why
uh i think that those of us who cared
about theory in the
in the 90s or 2000s were basically
misled
we we
we we had we thought okay let's stick to
convex problems and that was a mistake
okay and i've had these numerous
conversations with january i said okay
the one thing i got wrong was i didn't
have faith in sgd and i should have had
more faith and then i would have been on
to using these multi-layer neural
networks earlier than i was
uh there are phenomena which are being
found about uh
learning with uh the overfitting which
is kind of traditionally where all this
vc theory was developed and it turns out
there are arguments which say that these
current neural networks highly over
parameterized don't have overfitting
issues so there's the so-called
phenomena of double descent and so forth
these are interesting questions that
theoreticians need to tackle
and
but i think they will need to change
their style
their style is to work with pencil and
paper and try to think things through
no you have to operate like physicists
which means bury yourself in some
phenomena try to understand what is
going on see the puzzles and then try to
make sense of them rather than come in
with you know floating from 30 000 feet
above so the kind of work that i like is
theoretical work like what benrecht did
where they showed that
that that that neural networks could
essentially fit to any to this and get
zero training error on digits
even with all the digits being random
even with the labels being permuted now
that's a very intriguing finding and
this requires a combination of a
theoretical sensibility
and uh and and sort of having your hands
and feet dirty so
i think it's a different style of theory
which is needed the kind of theory which
is needed in biology is
different than than what is needed in
in
you know theoretical physics for example
and
our business is closer to biology
thank you
very provocative thank you uh uh dr
lindsay your your thoughts
um yeah i guess i have
a somewhat related kind of set of ideas
coming from the neuroscience side which
is about understanding these networks um
i'm very interested in taking a trained
neural network and trying to take the
tools that we use to understand real
neural data and apply it to the neural
network and see if we can try to
understand the trained neural network in
this kind of level of understanding
that's more satisfying to people kind of
this algorithmic level of describing it
in a few simple sentences that gives you
some intuition for um what this big
distributed set of neurons is
implementing um and so i'm interested in
that for the sake of understanding the
neural network for the sake of making
more types of comparisons between the
neural network and and uh real neural
activity so you can say oh if i apply
the same analysis do i get the same
result if i apply it to neural activity
and to artificial neural activity that's
another form of comparison but also i
think it's important for testing the
tools that we use in neuroscience
because we don't have a lot of kind of
ground truth in neuroscience you we have
very limited by some definitions very
limited experimental access to neural
activity and certainly to connection
weights we have very limited access we
don't know um how strongly neurons are
connected to each other and how they
influence each other in most of the
brain regions people are studying um so
i don't we've come up with all these
techniques that feel like they're giving
us intuition for how populations of
neurons are implementing computations
and what those computations are
but
if i've learned anything from trying to
study these artificial neural networks
it's that it's very easy to come up with
some story and then you test it and it
doesn't actually hold or you know once
you have full experimental access to
perturb the system um and record from it
and all of that uh your intuitions
change about how it could be working and
so i'm i'm interested for the sake
partly of understanding neural networks
but also for the sake of neuroscience
and the tools that it uses um to test
out the tools of neuroscience on
artificial neural networks
thank you dr dicarlo
your thoughts yeah well i'd love to talk
to everybody for a couple more hours
i'll just give you my my take-home
things i i'd like to i think it's
important for people to keep in mind the
point that chitanda made about these
different types of answers the kind of
how answers like how visual inference
even works and that's where most of our
work is centered but there's also a
relay question how the thing learns to
become what it is which we've talked
about and then there's the why questions
as mentioned and those are just keep in
mind those are different questions and
people are often confused with them i
think it's important to always keep
clear what questions being asked the
good news that i'd like to highlight is
on the how the visual system does
inference how it does visual inference
at least on paths of latent object
content um and other latent variables
like pose and position there's been huge
progress we now have decent models of
how the visual system appears to do that
at the single neuron level those models
are now in existence and they weren't 10
years ago and they were conceptual
models that have now been turned into
models that have predictive power and i
think that's something that good news
shouldn't be
forgotten it doesn't mean it's the end
it just means there's been a lot of
advanced now to i want to also make the
point we haven't talked about this much
some of my colleagues say why would we
use deep nets they imply there should be
another family of models to a
neuroscientist the brain is a recurrent
deep neural network ramoni kahal told us
that 100 years ago that's the central
dog in the field it's never it's not
going to change unless we start thinking
glia cells are doing all the work unless
there's a dramatic transformation a
brain is a recurrent deep neural network
so the game is figure out which one it
is and how it learns so
we're stuck with deep nets in that broad
sense forever uh unless there's a
transformation of the world so keep that
in mind and i i last point i'd like to
make is um
tundra mentioned you know kind of 20
there or big breakthroughs keep in mind
that's that's sort of the behavioral
side that's a computer vision is like
behavior to neuroscience like how well
you do various tasks how it matches that
we're kind of there's tons of detail
that to be sorted out on the
neuroscience side at what level how do
the genes relate to the dendrites that
then relate to building all of those
detailed connections up to
the behavior is really the dream of
neuroscience and these models are are
not even yet engaged on those questions
but they're opening the doors to allow
them imagine a day when i could give you
a crisper modification to your adult
genome that will modify your visual
cognitive behavior those are the kind of
models that you dream about that event
grumps are step one of that possibility
and that that frontier can only be
engaged on the on the biology side
regardless of if computer vision gets to
100 or 20 percent or if there aren't any
more breakthroughs in in jitendra's
words so there's a lot of exciting work
to be done
now these models are starting to engage
with and i think that's the future we
should all be excited about as humans
with one of these networks running in
all of our heads thanks
wow um well thank you very much
my sincere thanks to all of you uh this
has been a wonderful uh discussion i
wish like uh dr dekala said we could
keep talking for another two hours
uh but i'm also
sorry that we couldn't take all the
questions there are some 20 odd
questions still outstanding but i think
we have answered some of them
you know during the course of this
conversation so but apologies to the
people who
wrote questions but we couldn't get to
those um yeah thank you again very much
for participating as this has been
wonderful i will
pass the microphone to prasad in calvin
hall to
see if he has anything to say and then
we will conclude
thanks again to anil james uh grace
and santosh for the lively discussion
you've given us a lot to think about
thanks to the audience for participating
and we hope to see you all again soon in
the next
talk on the series thank you
thank you
thank you for having us
yes my pleasure thank you all it's been
wonderful
i will connect with you all separately
bye